- This video is brought to you by Nope.
(upbeat music)
What's up, everybody?
Michael here for a piss-soaked quick take
on South Park's The Streaming Wars Part 2.
As expected, this chapter, The
Streaming Wars made us laugh.
- Butters, Butters.
My eyes are up here, stop
staring at my (beep).
- Throw up in our mouths a little bit.
(character puking)
And speculate about the marital dynamics
of ManBearPig and PigBearGirl.
But is there something deeper going on
beneath all the urine jokes?
And can a piss-filled water park
in a drought-ridden South Park
teach us about how businesses
function in times of crisis?
Let's find out in this
wise crack quick take,
can fake boobs save the planet?
And, of course, spoilers ahead.
But, before we dive in,
I want to tell you about
this week's sponsor.
Jordan Peele's new film,
Nope, is out on July 22nd.
And, honestly, we cannot wait.
Both Get Out and Us
operate in a long tradition
of using genre fiction
to discuss the black
experience in America.
Nope takes this trend and does a left turn
towards science fiction.
Now in Us, Peele explored
double consciousness.
The idea that black identities
are fractured to fit the various roles
they're expected to play
in a racist society.
Now, Get Out shows the
limit of a liberalism
that is only skin deep.
It successfully interrogates
the fetishization of black people,
and the way that many are willing
to just use them for their own ends,
whether they be political
or simply for entertainment.
Now, knowing that Peele is
such a master of using genre
to explore big ideas,
we cannot wait to see
how he uses sci-fi to blow
our minds even further.
And all of us are super
excited to get out and see Nope
in theaters on July 22nd.
And now, back to the show.
In our last South Park video,
we explored how The Streaming
Wars uses water supply,
or lack thereof,
as both a literal plot point
about environmental crises,
and a metaphor about the state
of today's streaming economy.
Unsurprisingly, this thread
continues into part two
because Matt and Trey clearly
still feel very aggrieved
by their 900 million dollar
deal with Paramount Plus.
- It was not my fault streaming
services pay people more
than what's sustainable
in any business model.
- Anyway, part one ends
with our sweet mom and pop streamers,
Randy and Tolkien's dad, Steve,
being wiped out by the biggest
streamer of all, Pi Pi,
who's gonna solve South
Park's water scarcity problem
by becoming a barren of recycled piss.
Also, any Italians watching,
let us know in the comments
if Pi Pi is a racist character,
or if you can even have a racist
representation of Italians?
I don't know.
Let us know in the comments
when you're done eating your meatballs.
After all, the city's
very thirsty residents
have no other option.
Oh, and Cartman still
has massive fake boobs.
In part two, Pi Pi returns
with a kingdom of monetizable piss,
and he has big dreams for
his wee-wee water slide
to supply South Park with
enough pee for every faucet,
popsicle mold, and pasta pot in the land.
In the absence of water,
urine has become an abundant
affordable resource,
and Pi Pi controls it all.
It's a perfect example of
how the market can find ways
to profit off of just about anything.
In this instance, Pi Pi
is using a real problem
affecting the life and health
of a community, a drought,
to create a great business
opportunity for himself.
And the show is clearly pointing out
that this happens all the
time in the real world.
Just ask anyone who bought
stock in Moderna and Pfizer
in the spring of 2020,
which I don't know if that
makes you a bad person,
but it felt weird, it felt
weird when people did that.
According to scholar, David Harvey,
"Crises shake our mental
conceptions of the world
and our place in it to the very core.
And we, as restless
participants and inhabitants
of this new emerging world, have to adapt,
through coercion of consent,
to the new state of things."
In other words, crises
are a great opportunity
for those with power to rework
things for their benefit.
And we see this in Matt
Damon's favorite hobby,
cryptocurrency trading, which
South Park continues to roast.
Well, it might not be as exploitative
as holding water supplies hostage,
lots of folks without money to spare
have lost ridiculous
amounts buying crypto,
and celebrity-ridden ads for crypto
are clearly playing in to
current economic anxieties.
And while crypto is a good example,
this is just what the market
economy does in general,
namely, finds a way to
profit off human necessities,
food, housing, medicine,
while creating desire
for things we don't need,
multiple streaming services,
speculative currencies,
fake boobs for our moms.
And Damon is back for The
Streaming Wars Part 2.
And this time he and his celebrity friends
are getting paid so much
that they're willing
to drink recycled piss.
It's shockingly not too
far off from reality.
Recently, fellow
influencer, Kim Kardashian,
has told interviewers
she'd eat her own (beep)
if it would keep her looking young.
I drink my own piss and
it keeps me looking old.
Um. (laughs)
Of course, these celebrities
can endorse things like cryptocurrencies
because their finances
are already good to go.
It'll be the naive consumer
who risked their
financial future on crypto
just because Matt Damon told them that--
- Fortune favors the brave!
- Fortune favors the brave. (gags)
- At least when you buy a
Jennifer Lopez endorsed shampoo,
it's not gonna ruin your retirement plan.
But instead of focusing on
crypto, this episode dives
into the depths of Pi Pi's piss palace,
which exists solely because he
took out the other streamers
to give himself a stranglehold
over South Park's water,
exacerbating an environmental crisis
to help turn a public good,
water, into profitable business.
And now he's poised to make bank
by selling people's piss back to them.
And this is what writer
and activist, Naomi Klein,
calls "disaster capitalism."
Orchestrated raids on the public's sphere
in the wake of catastrophic events,
combined with the treatment of disasters
as exciting market opportunities.
And Pi Pi is far from the first person
to spin (beep) situations into major coin.
America has pulled a much
larger version of Pi Pi's move
in several South and
Central American countries.
- That is somebody who has
helped planned coup d'état.
Not here, but you know, other places.
- Like Chile, where
they helped the military
carry out a violent coup in 1973
on behalf of Augusto Pinochet,
who would go on to rule
with stunning brutality.
After the coup, Milton
Friedman and his acolytes
from the Chicago School of Economics
helped install a shiny
new free market economy.
Still reeling from political violence,
Chile had the perfect conditions
for what Friedman called
economic "shock treatment."
Fearful of communism and eager to exploit
economic opportunities
in countries like Chile,
America repeatedly backed military regimes
that privatized public industries,
turning public wealth into private profit.
And, rest assured, American
corporations saw plenty of money
to be made in these new markets.
And yet, the actual economic
results were catastrophic.
As client rights, Chile's
economy shrank 15%
in the first year of "shock therapy,"
while unemployment grew
from 3% to a staggering 20%.
And America used this same playbook
during the War on Terror.
According to Klein,
the Bush administration
used the trauma of 9/11
to exploit all the economic opportunities
that come with decades-long wars.
They essentially launched a new economy.
- Because the parameters of this economy
were extraordinarily wide.
This is an endless war.
We were told that the enemy
could not be reasoned with.
There could be no diplomacy.
There could be no discussion.
There could only be attack.
And that it would not end
until evil was defeated everywhere, right?
So if you think of it as a business plan,
it could hardly be more profitable.
Because basically what you're saying
is you've got this new market,
it's never gonna end, and
we have unlimited funds
to finance this new market.
- And in the case of Pi
Pi's empire, we've got shock
and a seemingly limitless market.
So what can we do when faced
with the overwhelming forces
of disaster capitalism?
Klein generally concludes
that when unfettered private
markets control society,
it can empower bad actors.
And no, she doesn't mean Gwyneth Paltrow.
And that to counter this,
we need both greater
regulation of industry,
and an economy where certain
industries and infrastructures
are publicly owned,
where certain human needs
are not subject to the
whims of the market,
but guaranteed rights to everyone,
and a world, where in
the face of disaster,
rather than predatory
capitalist descending,
the devastated communities themselves
are empowered to rebuild.
We see this happen to some extent
when Randy stops being a Karen
and decides to reembody who he used to be,
a talented scientist,
who's uniquely qualified
to solve South Park's water problem.
And after some public
cajoling and a massive deck,
he gets the local government to pour money
into his ocean water desalination project.
After a few less relevant plot points,
Randy eventually finds the solution
to the town's water problem
in Cartman's distractingly huge boobs.
- How to get salt water to
the desalinization plant?
Salt water, sailing, saline
in the plant, saline implant!
Holy (beep)!
- [Michael] And at first glance,
it seems like they simply found
a Barstool Sports friendly
answer to their problem.
It's sort of like ads
from power companies,
asking us to use less power
during the hottest months.
Somehow, if those in
charge can't seem to manage
their massive power grid,
it becomes our individual responsibility
to keep things running during peak demand.
We didn't cause these problems.
We can't really fix them,
but we are asked to take
on the responsibility
of making things a little less bad.
Individuals are asked to sacrifice
while governments and corporations
keep it business as usual.
If this sounds like a
discouraging bummer, it is.
And we see this defeat isn't
at the end of the special.
- We have enough water for the summer now,
(beep) it.
Let's smoke some weed!
- The group decides it would
be too much of a hassle
to kill Chuck Chuck,
and therefore solve
climate change forever.
And they know it'll take a lot more
than an army of saline-filled double Ds
to truly mitigate large scale drought,
but it's like, "It's hard work,
so why not enjoy ourselves a little bit
before we all become dried out raisins."
But, what do you think?
Have South Park's Streaming Wars shown us
the depraved depths of
disaster capitalism?
Or is this just a fun 50
minutes of urinal humor?
Let us know in the comments.
Thanks to our patrons
for all their support.
And don't miss out on
our new Patreon perks.
They're very good.
Also join us for our weekly
live stream every Thursday
right here at 11:00 AM Pacific.
Be sure to like this video,
hit the subscribe button,
ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching.
I'll see you later.
(electronic music)